investigators in Brazil are trying to
determine what caused a massive fire
that engulfed a 200 year old National
Museum in Rio de Janeiro last night more
than 20 million historical artifacts
were destroyed some 80 firefighters were
called in to battle the brave the blaze
and president Michel temer called it a
sad day for all Brazilians anne-marie
green is following this ann-marie good
morning good morning well firefighters
got a slow start to putting out the
flames because two of the fire hydrants
closest to the building were not working
the fire started Sunday evening after
visiting hours so it was closed to the
public at the time firefighters and
several museum workers would race to
save the museum's relics it took more
than three hours to put out the flames
the museum had a vast collection of
artifacts donated by the Brazilian royal
family the national treasure house
artifacts from Egypt greco-roman art and
the first human remains found in Brazil
dating back almost 12,000 years the
museum was connected to University so
some of the pieces were spared from the
fire it's not immediately clear just how
the fire began though and there are no
reports of injuries
yeah all right Anna Marie thank you